the cross tourer is billed as an all
roads version of a Citroen c5 wagon
it comes with an array of driver assists
fitted a standard and a classic set to
an gimmick first impressions our car
reviewer Montes finds it a bit odd the
way the steering wheel turns but the
center section does not and again if you
have a collision while going around a
bend you can be sure the airbag will
deploy straight at you
meaning proper protection so it is
practical is one pocket
the c5 has a reputation for sound
handling the cross term makes no secret
of its weight however the handling is
such reflects how big and heavy the
color is montes finds it a bit sluggish
the steering response is a little
indirect although you don't feel as if
it's unsafe the Crosstour comes with a
choice of three diesel engines the HDI
165 we tested is the second most
powerful option generating 120 kilowatts
and propelling the car to 100 km/h in
9.3 seconds official fuel consumption is
5.1 liters overall Mathis likes the
interior workmanship some sections are a
bit sloppy like this edge of plastic
sticking out light colored thing poking
out by the fan except for those minor
cosmetic flaws the interior works
the cars exterior look is enlivened by
fender flares long roof bars and 18-inch
alloy wheels chrome effect wing mirror
caps and brushed metal style protective
trim on the front and rear skirting add
a touch of French chick to the new sit
when the cargo section encompasses 533
litres a nice feature is the detachable
trunk lamp doubling up as a practical
flashlight
the interior is uncluttered with a
pleasant touch to the materials the
driver is particularly pampered with the
heated seat also boasting a massage
function the high directive three-plus
suspension can be raised by six or four
centimetres to boost the car's off-road
caliber albeit only at speeds under 40
km/h Montes isn't really satisfied on
the one hand you can raise the body
really high which is very practical on
rough terrain but with a slightest bit
of rain you can't go off-road
front-wheel power means insufficient
traction the Crosstour has its strengths
the dynamic exterior the hydropneumatic
suspension and the smart assists but it
also has its drawbacks a 37 thousand
euro price tag in Germany means the
Citroen c5 cross tourer is no bargain
but not that expensive either if a word
for the restriction to front-wheel drive
the idea would be perfect perfect